[Music]
hey what's up everyone welcome back to
the lobby gamespot's weekly hangout it
is 11 a.m pacific time here in san
francisco california i'm your host mike
mccarty we have a pretty heavy show
today there are a lot of games out this
week a lot of reviews uh some of which
we're only gonna be able to touch on in
passing but like i said pretty packed
show i'm here with rob handlery hi
you're probably pretty tired right we
were streaming some call of duty today
yeah well yeah streamed the trailer
afterwards we we did we saw the trailer
and uh
yeah it was funny i was looking at
comments and i think i agree with the
one guy who says i've never been so
overwhelmed
by a trailer and i was like damn that's
exactly how we all fell after so we'll
definitely dive into that later i i
don't think like
anything in my life has changed since
watching that trailer yeah
right at all uh michael heim you were
there i was there playing call of duty
3. yeah i was getting wrecked by ai yeah
my bad if you all want to watch me get
wrecked you can re-watch that stream but
uh yeah i'm feeling feeling all right
mouse and keyboard ready for you yeah
please um but yeah like like rob said i
was overwhelmed by the trailer
i mean yeah we can get into that later
but yeah what's up kelly plaggy you like
world war ii shooters i do uh i saw more
of call of duty world war ii than um
what was shown today
um so i was
more than whelmed with some of it um i
have impressions on the site now but i
had similar feelings about the trailer
just kind of like all right that sure is
a trailer
yeah
yeah if you join us on twitch or youtube
chats we're on gamespot we have those up
so you're joining us we always
appreciate your input i've got a bunch
of twitter questions uh cali's going to
talk a little bit more about call of
duty what she saw kind of behind closed
doors last week uh and now her like she
just said her impressions are up on the
site if i go check those out after the
stream um we're gonna be talking about
mario kit kart eight on the switch
uh what remains of edith finch which is
kind of generating some buzz after
reviews glowing reviews are coming out
more of a narrative game uh we'll touch
on dragon quest heroes dawn of war three
and outlast two and then also like i
said we'll get more into world war ii
shooter realm later on uh first as usual
i have a giveaway um
bear with me while i get this it's down
here ooh what are we giving away
these are tough to bring up
yeah is it heavy yeah yeah
here we go if you are nailed it an rts
fan
this is not black ops 3 this
is dawn of war three um
special edition it comes with i don't
know how well we're gonna be able to see
that from there but you got this like uh
hammer miniature
uh as well as some uh some dlc stuff art
book the usual kind of stuff and this
huge box
uh
which leads me to the next thing but uh
well uh if you don't follow gamespot on
twitter go follow us retweet the tweet
about the giveaway shiva who manages our
twitter account we'll be posting a
twitch chat soon if you're not on twitch
don't worry just go on twitter um
retweet game spots tweet and later in
the week we'll pick a random winner in
north america uh and
see if rob can get that back down
without breaking it
success
landed on its feet um
yeah so that's the giveaway for the week
uh if you're a pc rts fan uh dawn of war
three if you want to go read uh daniel
starkey of freelancer his review he uh
gave it an eight out of ten uh we also
pretty soon have uh behind the scenes
look at relic and the history of relic
entertainment how they dealt with the
thq fallout um and how dawn of war iii
actually began its lifespan which is
pretty cool it used to be like
four separate games that got compounded
into one once relic moved on from
company of heroes too it's a really
fascinating behind the scenes look uh
dave jewett adam mason tomorrow saying
over in our uk office worked on it uh
that will be up soon i believe
if not tomorrow then very soon this week
uh i just finished watching it myself
before we publish it it's really good
you should check it out uh anyway uh
another game that came out recently that
we won't be able to touch on too much uh
miguel concepcion reviewed dragon quest
heroes 2
kind of a mashup of the dragon quest rpg
series uh the characters the world of
that with more dynasty warriors uh
what's the term mussol thank you very
much fighting uh like battle although
this miguel was saying this leans more
toward the jrpg side than the first
dragon quest heroes did um i was gonna
play this last night i got caught up
with outlast two but
you gotta love the toriyama art too it
it is gorgeous i was watching like
conversations and cut scenes and it was
just fantastic um and yeah like the
character designs of the dragon quest
series or
i guess for people who don't know
toriyama did dragon ball so
gotcha partial to his art style it does
look very good yeah um
and yeah so go check out miguel's review
gave it an 8 out of 10. i look forward
to playing that a little bit tonight it
looks pretty fun it looks like it's
doing some new things for the series but
unfortunately we don't have a ton of
time to talk about today because we have
so many other things to talk about uh
one news item i wanted to mention was uh
resident evil 7's not a hero dlc was
delayed i won't spoil there's i guess
it's kind of a spoiler who it features
you can go google that easily nevermind
he's right there that's uh chris
redfield in the background features him
uh you can
play as him but they delete it uh here
you have uh
kawada on the right producer who was the
one who said uh that they wanted to
delay it just to make sure it lived up
to the quality of the base game and uh
so they don't have a definite release
date yet but that will be free when it
releases and they said they're also
working on
another one
uh
simultaneously
so i'm looking forward to that and cool
let's jump into our show so uh
justin clark a freelancer for a game
spot gave what remains of edith finch a
nine out of ten
and uh this game's like a more narrative
linear story driven game derogatory term
being walking simulator for those who
like uh call them that you know like in
the vein of gone home or uh dear esther
things like that firewatch um michael
you played it last night i sure did beat
in about three hours you said yep
so hit me with it try it like in a
nutshell what is this game because i'm
i've been confused about that so uh
edith you play as edith finch and it's
no mystery that your family has died of
really strange
causes but you know your job is to
figure out how that happened because if
you go to the pause menu you open up
your book you see your family tree in
case you didn't know her name from the
title uh
there it is on her journal
so you would open up her journal and um
yeah it starts off
heard telling you what's going on but
when you open the journal in the menu
you see your family tree and everyone's
life spans and many of them have been
cut short
and you don't know that the [ __ ] is that
the weasley house
yes
the burro
[ __ ]
flying car coming in
oh it's not it's not that so it's not
like that at all where have you been
all right yeah well you go through their
house and their house is basically a
like that's what drives all the
narratives so you visit each of their
rooms
and you
kind of you look through their room you
read their journal entries you look
through photos and then it'll take you
to a separate
uh gameplay element where you kind of
play what play themselves the person who
died and through that you find out what
happened to them and there's some really
strange things you're unraveling it's
like is it mostly environmental
storytelling is it is it in the vein of
gone because gone home is one of my
favorite games of the past decade
probably i mean i it's really important
to me is it is it kind of in that
similar yeah you get some you have some
high key uh gone home vibes from it when
you say strange you mean
they are strange or like atmospherically
or
you know
magic strange strange as in um
doesn't the aesthetic of the house
change throughout like someone was
saying there's a huge variety of
environments even though you're in like
a house the whole time when you when you
go into each person's kind of life story
that's when the house changes because
you almost gotcha time travel through
what happened to them at their last
moments okay so that that's kind of what
and going back to what you asked like
there's no it's not very supernatural
like but strange as in
um there's it's a combination of things
uh some suffer from what i think is some
sort of mental illness some suffer from
just boredom or
some are just
died through
accidents and it's for you to kind of
unravel like the more mysterious ones
are very esoteric
and you almost have to like make up your
own mind about what it means did you
read that yeah did you read that that
was me i did not my grandma spent seven
years sharing a bedroom with her dead
brother yep
stuff like that that's not so strange
before
whoa my brother's he's dying but he's in
my room um
before we move on to your uh your like
critiques of it because i want to get
you now that you played through it i
know you haven't had a lot of time for
it to stew uh like i said justin clark
reviews up on gamespot but i do have a
question from twitter apologies for
pulling on my phone for this which you
can't even see right now but um john
christian jensen
asks which family member story and what
remains
was your favorite made the biggest
impact can you talk about that without
spoilers like
or like is there like one tonally that
you like there is one that stood out
very clear to me
for like personal reasons or is it like
a horror thing i heard there's some
horror elements this game there are some
horror elements but there's no it's not
nothing like resident evil 7 but in
terms of the one that stood out to me
damn i forgot his name because i just
played it yesterday but it's towards the
end when you get to the top of the house
it has
how do i not spoil this though you you
play as him he's like in uh he works in
the cannery so he's like cutting up fish
for his job naturally but his mind
travels elsewhere throughout his job
because he has a mundane job and he has
like a really wild imagination like the
secret life of walter mitty
sure
my bad i'm not no
that's fine
don't spoil it you're good but then it
it what i really like about it what yeah
is this the grandmother thing this is
the grandma john luke accidentally
pulled up eagle flight footage for this
uh let's get back to you the finch thank
you john luke
no this is this is part of it
oh that's life eat that [ __ ] yeah
get in there good get in there guys you
hungry now is this united oh speaking of
hungry
yeah just everything i was gonna say
this is everything
okay this this part actually made me
laugh really hard that should have as if
you're a normal human being with it's so
cute it's like with a half a brain that
should make you laugh
it's so cute though um i mean really
weird stuff and it's a combination of
moments like this where you're happy and
laughing and it's silly but then you're
hit with like okay so
what
like okay i'm done i'm gonna interject
here so uh something we talked about
with everything a while back was like
the comedy didn't always mix with the
more like introspective stuff it sounds
like with edith finch
it meshes better or the
the tonal shifts didn't jar you as much
right like it from what you're saying it
sounds like
they mesh well together
oh god i can't get over this shark yeah
this is one of the more
strange i keep saying that word but it's
really weird yeah
but each sequence makes you do a
different gameplay thing so it's not
like you're turned into an animal all
the time right but like those those
shifts from like this sort of thing
versus my
grandma slept next to her dead brother
or whatever like that doesn't
is that jarring at all
i mean i
i kind of expected this to be
out there and then yeah you turned out
yeah it's just a rope dude i don't like
it no that's a snake man shut up it's
it's hard to talk about without spilling
the beans because part of the enjoyment
is discovering what am i going to turn
into when i
unravel this person's story or
this like my uncle who did this so each
each sequence is very different
it tells a different story but it all
ends up very sad like even the even the
happy moments result in death like
that's not that's yeah because
everybody's dead yeah all y'all's dead
so
it's no mystery that they are dead it's
just how they died and what they left
uh for the family is what you want to
uncover and
yeah i was gonna say something about how
i felt about how the ending kind of
brings everything together but i think
i'll say that because
i mean
in terms of pacing did you ever get
bored during this i mean it's three
hours long but did it kind of earn all
those minutes it did yeah there was
never a part where it's like oh i gotta
i gotta get through this part this is
like so boring um there there's one one
critique i do have of it is that some of
the
parts like the movement itself is very
slow and it's kind of like what am i
gonna get to
get to this end of the room did you
remember everybody's gone to the rapture
that was the game
initially this game reminded me of it
yeah it's very much like that oh the
heavy text kind of like uh i don't know
that like bloom yeah i remember uh marty
sleeva from ign did not know that you
could run in that game and so it was
like extra slow yeah like it was like a
mystery run button so yeah yeah that's
what i thought of too because ain't no
sprinting in this game
but i mean it's fine uh i think yeah
sometimes it works to its advantage
because i want to stop in the rooms and
look at the books that are there the
photos the right the scribbled notes
stop and smell the photos
exactly yeah it sounds like there's a
lot of environmental storytelling in
addition to like because sometimes i
feel like words coming up on the screen
can be heavy-handed like especially when
it's like yeah that's one thing i
appreciate about this game it's not it's
not heavy-handed it doesn't like tell
you everything like oh this person died
because of this it's more like this is
what happened it's up to you to decide
what that means to you so the overt
narration uh the written text doesn't
get in the way i mean the reason i love
gun homes because they didn't have any
of that if you didn't want to pick
something up and read it it's not it's
not text heavy though like you'll you'll
see on screen edith will think to
herself and that will be displayed in
text on the screen but it's usually like
a sentence or two it's not like she goes
into this exposition and monologue so
yeah the pacing is
aside cool
a good three hours yeah tough game to
talk about without spoiling but if you
all watching on twitch or youtube want
to go check out our review justin clark
of freelance for gamespot has it up on
gamespot now give it a nine out of ten
it's getting good scores across the
board so and it's like three hours
what'd you play on pc pc yeah yeah uh
you can go check that out today if you
want uh that is out
and uh
we'll be able to maybe talk about it
more if uh if you have gotten the chance
to play let me know in the chat and we
can uh just don't spell anything because
i wanna play it
cool
um all right moving on to another game
came out yesterday
rob and i played outlast two last night
for a little bit um i've also played a
little bit about listening and kelly
played ls2 um
first time i played it was a demo at pax
seas 2015. um and that was kind of like
a grab bag of what was going on in the
game there's like these poltergeist
sections in a school there's these more
uh like weird kind of
uh texas chainsaw massacre farm rural
resident evil 7 vibes and then
the thing that the demo
excited me
was the fact that it was actually kind
of a cool
uh
like
smorgasbord of this stuff like that but
it felt like it was doing well like
pacing well uh but i played more last
night and i think i had more positive uh
reaction than you did i don't know i
haven't played enough to really have a
strong opinion of it to uh to preface
this scott butterworth who has uh since
left gamespot uh and he will be missed
uh editor he it was his last review he
gave it a seven out of ten and i can get
through his thoughts as well like a few
of them i don't wanna you know you can
go read that right now it's well written
and stuff and he can convey that better
with that than i can just uh with bullet
point list but uh from our i wanted to
also give our
initial impressions but uh yeah scott
was saying it it's scary the tonally and
in terms of atmosphere it nails it uh
sound design he says it's one of the
better well-designed games in horror um
but it kind of can get repetitive and as
opposed to the first game which took
place in this
little more open asylum it was kind of
gated at certain points by certain items
or um characters that you need to talk
to this game's a little more linear and
sometimes we get into this chase
sequences which the first one kind of
popularized it also popularized first
person horror but this one um when
you're running you still have that
mechanic to hold like l1 or lb and look
behind you which can kind of heighten
the intensity god that's that part is so
scary yeah um
but sometimes it's too specific where
you need to run to uh it can get
frustrating if you don't really know
what they want you to do to avoid an
enemy uh i found that last night almost
like one of the first enemies i uh
encountered i was like what do they want
me to do it's right here yeah no this is
the i was about to mention the sequence
is yeah this i did not like this this
bish and i
i like died several times when i was
playing because i couldn't figure out
like where it wanted me to go it was
super fast yeah um and it wasn't it was
like almost
a very specific thing that i had to do
at least maybe we found but i mean it's
frustrating because it's it's definitely
very yeah it stops being scary after the
second time when you're like okay now i
just need to figure out the gamified
thing and then it's like you have to end
up um kind of crawling under this hole
and it's hard to see which that itself
isn't bad but it's like
i don't know it's it's not clear how
quickly you have to run to escape her
and i totally felt like she was gonna
grab me from the hole and like that
didn't happen it was just it was
it was not smooth
yeah like i
i'm thinking of just the last resident
evil right where if they catch you
generally you can
you know you're still in it well you
also smack around and then and then you
and then you keep running i mean to be
in defense of
outlast two resident evil you had a
plethora of weapons to use against
enemies yeah unless you mean when they
actually grabbed you which yeah you
could still block in this game you're
much more defenseless yeah like that
first part like after i finally got
through it it just left me with the yep
yeah all that the fifth time she stabbed
you in the genitals kind of wears off
that's what i said to you uh yeah
i felt like it was excessive
wait no hold on no
yeah
that's what you said you said after the
fourth time they penalized me for
getting caught and then you gave me this
stare and there's like wink wink god i'm
good back to outlast honestly though
like it was just
i was like just getting over it
the fifth time i'm watching
that area get ripped in half
replaced by a scythe yeah like i i don't
know it's it's a little much for sure
but but i i i can't say anything i mean
i want to keep playing because you know
uh i feel like mike you have a pretty
good taste in games so i mean i believe
you when it when you say that it gets
better i mean that area was just
such a trial and error that i that i did
not enjoy um yeah again trying to find
one specific area
opposed to like now i was mentioning you
like in that same area that you know
there are all these doors that you are
um going up to and they could be locked
some of them just don't even have any
interactive problems like
it that frustrated me where i in that
moment i'm unsure of whether or not this
is even something i can interact with
like
it's hard to like it's hard to
experiment in that one moment but again
baby pig speaking of sound design yeah
the crunchy squishy noise oh really yeah
you're walking over them gross um but
yeah it actually in terms of uh so i do
have a question from
nikki j on twitter saying are jump
scares and chase sequences enough to
keep the horror genre alive both are
great but what can make the genre better
in relation to this game
definitely jump scares there's one
i've kind of
people around the games office know i
startle easily but there was one here
that genuinely got me um i don't know if
you guys got far enough but it was
very sudden but uh the chase sequences i
found i haven't i got to one like
scripted one but then if you ever get
discovered you can run to the next
checkpoint or wherever you're going um
but
i actually like what this game is doing
with this occult stuff and the farther
and you get the more you realize it's
actually not just
this grab bag of these kind of uh
cultist tropes it's actually there's a
story here there's two uh
there there is more to it than i
initially realized and i do like the
angle of uh shooting these things with
uh you know you use the camera to review
footage and he can actually present kind
of uh his insight into what's going on
in addition to yours but uh yeah i like
i like the
uh viewing it through the camera i got
like blair witch vibes from the occult
stuff because it's like at first um
i thought you know like i get really
weary of of a cult because it's like oh
it can so easily go into that like weird
trophy territory um but the further you
get it is more
interesting and oh god
write room if you ask me yeah
the gore stuff i actually didn't mind
but okay so the the
it reminded me of residual four you go
to this remote village uh this is in
arizona um
the resident before kind of the
las plagas and the ganatos and the uh
yeah
yeah um but this is
you know they're not as far as i'm into
the game and i'm not that that far
they're not zombies but uh but yeah so
scott was saying like the pacing goes on
well but yeah you can hide like amnesia
kind of you're defenseless she sucks
yeah
i hate how lanky she is that that gets
that gets me yeah yep
and you know the more you actually play
through the more they i think the
pacing's really good if you don't get
you can occasionally get caught up on
these certain chases and that does suck
because
in the first game you felt more like you
had options to escape rob like you were
mentioning kind of like resident evil
but this one it's much more linear than
the first game the first one was that
asylum and then you'd be like you go by
the basement you're like i don't want to
go down that basement right now that
sounds awful i can hear that person down
there but this stuff about this jessica
girl you start
having these
uh you hear your character's insight as
to what actually happened and then it
starts tying kind of you and a few other
characters together it actually
these flashbacks are pretty good and
that flashback is a weird term and if
you play the game you'll see why because
these aren't exactly flashbacks but it
ties into the main story really well and
i think so far and i want to play more i
think scott said he beat it in about 12
hours so it's decently lengthy game for
this kind of game so i could see where
that might wear thin
um but yeah i'm curious to see where it
goes yeah i feel like i it would take me
a long time to get through a 12-hour
game like this just because i would need
to take breaks because i get like
fatigued right that's how i was feeling
last night but i i i'm sure once i get
some speed into it then i can play for
longer yeah absolutely like doing a
three like sitting down for three hours
and playing after that i was exhausted
yeah yeah
um
yeah anyway i mean like i don't want to
talk too much about this without
spoiling it but in terms of the first
game so far i'm actually
kind of
underwhelmed because i think the first
game what i liked about it being one of
the games that popularized first person
horror i think uh what was that 2013 i
think that did a great job of putting me
in this asylum this setting which
everybody's done to silent this point
i'm glad they moved away from it but i
i like that like i said you have
multiple avenues to escape and you can
actually think through like scott
mentioned in this review you can kind of
think through
going to get this battery or this key
you need while this guy chases you but
you can maybe get back under that bed
before that happens but this one
outlast 2 feels too scripted so far to
me and i realize that's kind of allure
this this game maybe but i think they're
telling the story well i just think it's
kind of uh
i was just personally pulling me along
everyone's so lanky yeah it's like
slenderman i know he is like the
slenderman yeah the slenderman
but anyway yeah you can go read the full
review again by scott butterworth who
has left gamespot he will be missed but
that is his last review you can go read
that he gave it a 7 out of 10. uh it's
out as of yesterday on xbox one ps4 pc
uh you can go check it out so far i
recommend it um i think it's good and i
want to finish it among all the other
releases but
let us know what you think in the
comments below if you like the first
outlast do you plan on checking this one
out i don't know like how do you think
it compares to resident evil 7 what it
does differently what it does better
what it does worse and uh we'll look
forward to your thoughts
all right a game that has been out for
quite some time but not on this platform
cali plaguey you've been playing a lot
of mario kart 8 on this the year of our
good nintendo lords nintendo switch
release yes
yes tell us about it uh i reviewed it i
gave it a nine so obviously i really
liked it um i'm a big mario kart fan i
get a little too competitive maybe
um speaking of this friday we are doing
a huge tournament
live stream that you can totally tune
into i think right now it's set for 2pm
cool um
so yeah uh come to watch me destroy
everyone um
[Music]
aside i think the the biggest thing is
that um
i i was a little worried because i'm
like okay i've played
the heck out of mario kart 8 on
wii u um
why should i
return to this and one of the big draws
is they completely fixed battle mode
and that was a big focus of my review
because the the racing is very similar
it's still super great racing um but the
battle mode was like so underwhelming on
wii u and they just completely changed
it and added actual battle levels and
um what you're seeing here uh is
you know a return to form like if you
were a fan of like the n64 battle mode
um it's super fun like there's this bomb
mode where it's just like so chaotic um
so much fun is it different take on like
when you know if you died if you played
four to three people in 64 you became a
bomb is it similar to that no it's
you all item boxes are bombs you can
carry up to like 10 bombs at once and
your goal is to pop everyone's balloons
so it's like a variation of balloon
battle
which was the only mode available on the
wii u version and all the tracks were
actual race tracks so it didn't really
work very well um this one is just like
you're in these there's choke points and
there's like central areas where like
[ __ ] goes down
and it got really chaotic and we maybe
yelled while we were capturing all of
this
that's a good sign so it very much
sounds like it's worth returning to so
like you said even though you played a
lot on wii u you still found this uh fun
to come back to so how much of that is
the fact that
it's
and obviously i don't think this played
into your review but how much of that is
the fact that it's not like the one game
you're playing on a switch anymore it's
not just zelda you have something else
that kind of shows the switch is fun
like um that doesn't really have
anything to do with it because i do have
other games on switch that i'm playing
um
it's more i think the
like switch technology and this is sort
of weird thing that maybe not everybody
would notice but um playing it uh i
am a really big fan of drifting as you
can see um from any of this capture
and the the vibration in the joy-cons is
actually
so responsive and it feels much more
satisfying to execute actually um and i
was surprised by that i didn't think i
would notice that as much but it looks
great and it feels great to play um and
for me that was like oh now i feel more
rewarded going back to these that i've
already you know on wii u i got three
stars on every mode every cup and um all
the dlc and all that and this was like
oh i gotta do that again i gotta unlock
all these cart parts again but it was
actually really rewarding to do and part
of that was the feedback and i'm gonna
get blue shell oh no i'm not
um
yeah uh and then the other thing is uh i
i guess you do have a point that switch
it's not that i'm like oh now i have
something else to play on switch uh but
i do think
switch is a fantastic platform yeah and
for
uh mario kart especially i i really like
mario kart 7 on 3ds also um just because
i liked the portability factor and being
able to uh carry this around and we even
did in the office we did um sorry
[Music]
he got really steady
and she just bumped you off uh
yeah i
i was like i'm gonna get fired because
i'm trash talking too much um and then
that happened um
no uh i
i like like in the office we were able
to set the um
switch down we didn't have it docked and
we played four player split screen and
then that was bonkers and it hurt really
bad because uh drifting on the joy cons
is really hard so and you had like a two
inch screen to go off yeah
and your back hurt from punching over
trying to get yeah and i was hunching
over a desk um but what i like the point
of that anecdote is that it's um
that factor is like oh it adds this new
kind of way to play um and coupled with
battle mode it's kind of like
rediscovering what i liked about this
game originally so yeah homie3908 in the
youtube chat i was asking if you used
the pro controller at all for this uh
for this capture i did okay uh when my
regular playing i don't actually own a
pro controller um
so i didn't
for the review or any of the
normal gameplay i did you got some
drifting skills you got some depth
someone was saying that in the chat yeah
i'd be drifting in real life though so
oh
yeah they call me drifter waluigi i'm
excited i never uh i'm i was not a wii u
owner and i love mario kart uh namely
64. obviously like so many people and so
yeah like this is this is probably the
the real first multiplayer experience
for the switch like yeah absolutely like
i'm i am excited to like actually play
with other people and not four players
split screen
on one
uh screen but yeah like in the office
this should be fun friday as well um
it's great yeah it came and i came at a
good time because i mean i still love
playing zelda but um aside from other
things i've tried on it like uh like
snipper clips but i mean i'm looking
forward to splatoon 2 and i think like
you just said rob in terms of
multiplayer the mario kart 8 is you can
do a lot worse this is i mean this is
the the test run right for multiplayer
on switch we'll see how it works aside
from battle were there any other smaller
quality of life improvements on the
switch aside from just making use of the
uh like joy cons and whatnot yeah um
yeah i probably should have mentioned
that they added you can hold two items
at once so it has this little double
dash flavor which i like one of the
things about the wii u version is it was
very racing focused and i like that
i think the racing is really strong and
it's
the best mario kart in a while um but
having more items really keeps you on
your toes um there's just more items
being thrown at you and that can get
frustrating um but like i was just
getting hit by shells left and right and
it um added another dimension of
challenge like i feel like i've already
mastered these tracks and then now i
have to kind of adopt a new strategy and
like i built a cart with better
acceleration so i could recover from
shells and stuff like that um so i think
that's a small a small enough change
load times are a lot shorter
um and there was another thing how's the
frame rate but i don't know
seriously
i need some technical details
[Music]
no i'm just i'm just kidding
about that frame rate and i'm assuming
there are new maps and whatnot there's
no new um tracks for grand prix like
regular racing all the battle mode maps
are
new and actually work for battle um the
characters are already unlocked
and all the tracks in dlc is already
unlocked some people i talked to were
not stoked about that but i think you
also have to still unlock
your cart customization so there's still
level of progression there um that's
kind of the one thing that was a little
bit of a
i don't know not everybody i talked to
was super stoked about that i didn't
really care though i think a lot of us
prefer to play a multiplayer but when
you're playing solo did you prefer to
have it docked or do you like it
handheld or
um
played it mostly handheld
i just that's just my thing i love
playing handheld does it take the uh
like motion controls to play outside of
the joycons at all
um i don't play mario kart with motion
controls
um
i'll bumper drift in for you oh yeah
hell yeah yeah
i thought you'd have something funny
bumper rob's color commentary where's
that today we haven't gone to world war
two somewhere
oh jesus okay cool uh so yeah cali's
review is up on gamespot right now you
can go read it mario kart 8 for the
switch she gave it a 9 out of 10. final
thoughts
can we play it yes you should play it if
you haven't played it or if you thought
you were done on the wii u version you
should still play it if you have a
switch cool and like we said uh
friday we think 2 p.m pacific we're
going to start doing like an hour hour
and a half uh tournament kind of like
the rocket league one we did except not
stretch over a month
although that was fun uh if you if
you're a gamespot fan we did that last
year but uh this one will be uh a day
thing what does the winner get
uh honor have we decided yet no that's
not good enough i think there was never
very much for honor i think there was
talk of a trophy there was talk of a
trophy i hope it's beer
just a trophy made of beer or a playful
wait a beer trophy or just beer just
beer it's probably going to be their
beer regardless
i'm hosting
i'm announcer yeah
i'm so excited for that are you gonna
dress up do it like a nascar
commentator just not coming around the
corner kind of like an auctioneer except
about cars hey come around the corner
yes
oh my god can't she do it
on that note covered in spit ear drums
bleeding uh we're gonna move on to the
next segment but let us know if you plan
to return to mario kart 8 if you have a
switch uh do you want to return to it do
you want to get a switch just to play
this if you don't already want it for
zelda or something like that splatoon 2
or super mario odyssey later in the year
let us know what you think
in the comments below
all right
last segment i figured to be the longest
one so i allowed a lot of time for this
uh we
michael rob and i this morning came in
to play call of duty 2 3 and world at
war just kind of the more recent uh
world war ii call of duty games
uh leading up to the release uh
sledgehammer and activision's release of
call of duty world war ii the next
installment coming out november what's
the real estate third third thank you
and uh so we wanted to kind of get
callie's take she saw a lot more behind
closed doors it's up now on the site
right your impressions so uh go read
that after the stream or right now while
we're uh kind of talking about it here i
want to get your impressions of that
stuff but then i also kind of want to
move on to a broader discussion about
whether we even want to go back to world
war ii um
my answer has changed since i watched
the trailer today uh
not like super negative not to get into
that yet but um
it's worth talking about yeah you i was
whelmed by it just like who said that
somebody said it was a reddit comment
he's like wow
first off you know what threw me off
just while we were watching the trailer
oh he was right there that actor uh
what's his name josh demelle josh dumel
the last thing i saw him was the black
donnelly's a very short-lived i think fx
show about this irish uh family that
takes over the irish mob in boston that
was dope it was really good it got
canceled but that was the last thing i
saw him what else is he in
anything
that's what it is okay thank you i know
who you're talking of now yeah uh but
anyway uh kelly
let us know
what you there so there's stuff you
still can't talk about uh no it's all
right
i went to sledgehammer um to see some
behind the scenes stuff um and so i mean
this trailer is very much a
call of duty trailer uh but i got to see
a couple missions in action so um
obviously there's a normandy mission we
saw that um and then hurricane forest
which is known for the germans would um
do tree bursts which is when they would
put artillery into the trees to create
shrapnel that would rain down on the u.s
soldiers um and so we got to see that
sequence as well ouch um yeah and the
reason it worked so well is because u.s
soldiers were trained to uh
when they heard um artillery to fall
flat like on their stomachs and that
made them huge targets for shrapnel um
and so uh yeah so uh first i wanna talk
about normandy i think the the biggest
hang up i had is like i've seen
um normandy done we've all seen normandy
done um it's an iconic
uh world war ii moment for sure um but
there's uh this this one section that
really stuck out to me and it's when um
you're playing this like 19 year old
recruit who's like a private in the
fighting first from texas from
some state and yeah sure texas it is he
says at the end of the trip joshua's
from his character's from oklahoma so i
still had that in my head um but yeah
basically uh you're kind of going up the
beach as you do um and he has the uh
bangalore torpedo
um and he fumbles it like he just can't
get it to work um and i liked
moving um from previous call of duty
games i mean sledgehammers previous
being advanced warfare um and then i
played a lot of black ops 3 and not so
much infinite um but it's like it's nice
to return to something where you're not
overpowered super soldier like feeling
like this this is a kid who was thrown
into this war um and it's that little
detail that
made this game
like made me optimistic about it like oh
i like that
they're kind of acknowledging that most
these these guys were you know 17 18 19.
no training a week of basic and they
went
to war um and it seems like they're
they're trying to treat that with a lot
of respect and not over glorify this war
which has been over glorified for years
and years and years um so that stuck out
to me and then the hercules sequence is
actually super cool um and just when the
shrapnel is raining down it was like
reverberating in my chest we did watch
it in the theater so that the sound
system was good but um
yeah so i wrote all about that and how
those little details could really set
this apart
did you so
is it going to be the same character for
throughout the whole playthrough um
actually yeah yes that's the one of the
things i was most excited about that i
didn't write about too much because it's
not new for call of duty um
finest hour did this but uh you switch
perspectives to a female french
resistance fighter um so it's a sniper
sequence sort of like the russian sniper
in in finest hour and um
she
it sounds like it's going to be there
all gillied up basically um it's just
like a slower stealthier sequence but i
was really excited because i went into
this being like uh it's world war ii i
don't know if there will be any playable
women and then it was like just kidding
here's playable women for multiplayer
and single player um and so i was i was
actually really excited about that um
but it's mostly following the first
infantry division gotcha uh yeah in
terms of big red one call of duty big
red one did it before but it's
interesting to see because
i think a lot of the world war ii things
we've seen at least from the american
perspective is like these elite soldiers
saving private ryans they were rangers
banner brothers they were the one of
first paratroopers airborne uh and then
obviously you know you have uh like
marines in the pacific but the fact that
these are like draftees you said yeah
very two weeks of training that'll be
interesting and you're like
not people who wanted to be there didn't
really you know particularly say i want
to go into training so i have someone
well trained in the foxhole next to me
yeah i'm curious to see how they do that
because the trailer did not give me that
impression everybody in the trailer is
like let's get to work and i was like
see that's the thing that that
disappointed me so much about the
trailer is the trailer is very like ubra
call of duty word yeah war and um i
didn't get that sense from anything i
saw while i was there or anybody i
talked to i mean the whole team did so
much research and immersed themselves in
like super upsetting details about world
war ii and they have this military
advisor and everyone seemed really
dedicated to it when i talked to them
and of course part of that is like of
course you're going to
talk about that first and foremost um
but the the normandy sequence in
particular just doesn't feel like the
trailer makes the game seem um and
granted this is hands-off i saw gameplay
i didn't actually play it so that's
subject to change but my impression is
very different from what the trailer
creates and it seems like it's catering
to like
the the
idea of what a call of duty fan is
um and when i think of call of duty
going back to its roots i mean i
remember playing the originals and um
i just i've never considered myself part
of that
demographic um and so it's like you know
it seems like the game itself doesn't
isn't trying as hard to to cater to that
but the trailer was just so
it's just so
you know
it's too familiar yeah we've seen like
we were talking when we did like a
little bit of a breakdown
i don't want to see omaha beach again i
don't want to see utah beach right i
mean we're there are a couple shots that
are
clearly
uh influenced by
um
second part ryan over the shoulder over
the shoulder silhouette of the gunner
the fact that they hop off the right
side of the landing craft into the water
like that whole shot was just straight
from the movie so it's
you see that and you go well yeah i mean
i know what all this means i know you
know i know that movie everyone knows
that scene it's one of the most you know
culturally impacted uh
impactful scenes of like
you know cinema history like it's just
it was such a big deal so
yes they're going to pull from that
um but again just yeah hearing you talk
about it um
cali is is great because it i needed to
hear that i needed to hear a different
like take yeah other than looking at all
these familiar shots again this is not
the trailer we yeah
yeah i mean just to to conclude that
thought um from what i was saying
earlier it's like the the details and
the attention to detail that i saw in in
the sequences that that i got to see
that weren't in this trailer um are are
what could set it apart from being the
same old the same scenes we've always
seen um and so that's what
my hope is there but do you think that
you know they're they're going for
these saving private ryan-esque moments
that are almost like ripped from the
film if you think about it that movie is
almost 20 years old right and so do you
do you
feel like they're trying to make
something for a younger generation where
it's like you know these older games
that we made you probably haven't played
it so we're gonna kind of show that side
world war ii again but for a different
you know different generation yeah
actually 20 years ago that is a great
question
right
um no one of the uh sorry hold on a
second how old are you i'm 26. you're
feeling old yep you're younger than me
man i know i didn't say i feel all right
anyway
um
no kids these days
i talked to the animation director and
he basically said that exact thing was
like there's a whole generation who
didn't really have the same like world
war two media experience that kind of
all of us did um and so that's part of
kind of i don't think it's going to be
like a greatest hits of all the world
war ii missions everyone loves but um
because that would be my ultimate
nightmare and i hate that um
but it does seem like they're they're
trying to
reintroduce this for people for because
like uh one of the guys i talked to like
has an eight-year-old kid and this kid
is like yeah yeah dad we learned about
world war ii in school but like has no
context
for any of it um because it's been
20 years since
saving private ryan it's been 10 years
since the last world war ii call of duty
so that's
that's
might be what the
like hitting those familiar
scenes that's why 24. i feel like
sledgehammer and treyarch's and infinity
ward eventually started going futuristic
because they didn't have the uh i don't
know political ramifications because
call of duty the modern warfare series
was based it was fictional but it was
based on real events well i mean after
no russian like what are you well i mean
even the first game it was afghanistan
and iraq while this war was happening
that's in a lot of ways it's [ __ ] up
it was a fun game and i love that game
but that's still like
that war was nowhere out of our minds at
all it was still it wasn't it wasn't
ever declared war it was a conflict but
you want to actually say when you go to
like like iraqi freedom and they
depicted that it was kind of weird so
they went to the future games but now
they're kind of going back to antiquity
now that world war ii is coming back
around i feel like to avoid maybe some
sort of ramification and kind of push
back i don't know
yeah uh i mean i feel like you can still
get pushback from glorifying
uh you know
world war ii or not showing like you
know there's
my hope is that you know you have german
soldiers who are kids the same way the
u.s soldiers are and they're different
from the ss right like i i want to see
that nuance and like if they if they
didn't do that i would be like all right
well this is just another rehash of like
go america um
so i mean it's different
the the pushback would be different from
you know doing a war that is currently
being waged but is there any any hint to
that from the event you went to that you
know there might be more uh humanization
of your enemy or
other
people within that you
at war with uh because then i feel like
one of the more impactful moments like
we've all watched band of brothers
saving private ryan but then the behind
the scenes band of brothers stuff where
they interview these soldiers you know
in the early 2000s they're like you know
i remember i don't i forgot his name but
he was he was depicted in band of
brothers but he was like winners uh no i
wasn't winners i mean he's like shifty
he powers the sniper yeah he got in the
plane crash on the way back after the
war was done oh yeah he survived yeah
yeah and then he was like what if i went
fishing with that guy that german
soldier that i killed absolutely like
they probably would have been good
friends because we just want to like so
powerful piece and you know go fishing
and just enjoy nature
but you know we had to kill each other
for this war like i still haven't seen
that portrayed very much in video games
not that i'm like
you know asking someone to do that but
you know if you're gonna go back to this
there's a lot of nuance that you can
incorporate now that we've played so
many of these games that are more of
like
glorifications of war and the big scenes
like d-day and
operation market garden battle the bulge
we've seen that but where else can we go
with that setting
yeah that's what i want to ask you guys
i guess i could just go down the line i
don't know if you guys have certain
ideas but rob do you have any ideas what
you want them to do specific fronts you
want to see missions uh it looks like
it's going to be
it's an american squad but theater
western front mostly 44 to 45. about
missions in
europe
uh battle the bulge i feel like isn't
because that was a
horrifying battle i mean
just
you know holding those lines during the
winter and like what went through like
i'd like to see how that could be
depicted now again like with all the
humanizing tones like
just you know the banner brothers did
the the best portrayal that like you
know how they had to like get up and
push yeah and they're they have
frostbite
yeah no supplies no supplies they're
just
dropping
the environment
um anything like that i think would be
really interesting yeah
and
i
i like i'm curious to know how it would
end right because
i mean historically amer the americans
didn't hit berlin
right the russians hit berlin before us
so it's like how will how will this wrap
up and again i'll have to touch on
banner brothers band brothers
ended
very you know we talked about the last
two episodes of like that
series was more about like
how the soldiers like were holding
themselves after the war yeah shifty was
the one who said like how am i going to
explain this to people back home yeah
how are they like they're still the war
is over and they're still like
like you know
in uh occupied germany and they're like
fighting each other for the most part
like their own like um
comrades and everything but yeah i'm
really curious to see what route they
take yeah i don't know what about
youtube
michael um i mean i when they announced
that call of duty has come back to world
war ii i was like huh maybe i really do
want to like see this again because i
grew up like studying this stuff and
it's been a long time since i thought
about world war ii i mean you know i've
read a lot of books stephen ambrose and
and tom brokaw like their books of world
war ii were part of you know my interest
in this at a young age and then now that
i'm older i can kind of like
contextualize all that stuff and i play
a lot of video games i would like to see
some of that more
in-depth stuff portrayed at least in the
game you know if this is going to be
i mean i understand from reading your
preview that it's going to be you know
you're you're playing this guy and you
have a tight-knit squad and it's more
about
at least from what i got from your
preview is that like not just the war
but the war within himself that's what
it sounds like yeah like having to deal
with this major conflict at such a young
age like that's cool i think that that
if they if that's executed correctly or
well enough like that that'll be enough
to hold my interest
um but at this point you know i want to
see different environments i want to see
parts of the war that i may not know
about
and but i'm gonna you know i'm
gonna play through this and see what it
has to offer yeah um i think the biggest
thing for me is they really stress like
wanting to put you
[Music]
in like they wanted to put you in that
situation like make you feel like you
were there um i don't think that any
piece of media can act can really do
that um
and
uh i also want to see the like
ramifications of war executed properly
uh one of my favorite novels uh when i
was younger was a separate piece and i
liked that because it was never about
the the war i mean it was set during the
war but it was more about
people and it sounds like i mean this is
a very character-driven story but if
it's not executed properly i think it
can really just
fall totally flat um and so i just
haven't seen enough of character um or
of like the plot or narrative around
them to really get a feel for that and
so that's like my biggest um unanswered
question
do you guys think like call of duty is
the franchise that would be the first
one to really portray war in a
meaningful way
i mean i think
if you like it's the probability like i
don't i can't even stress
every time i look at numbers it's insane
uh i mean like we know it sells well and
we're not dumb but like it's it's huge
do you think something this big would
take that risk
i mean well that's how they started so
they have that foundation to but that's
not how they started they started with
called what 2003 was called duty and
that was just like that wasn't they
didn't say anything meaningful about
that they just portrayed world war ii i
don't think they ever have i mean like
pre-release for infinite warfare they're
like we're gonna put you we're gonna
show you what it means to
i mean i'm just playing devil's app yeah
but i think they have to we kind of
talked about how tired like i mean
the they are tired of
i think they have to i think yeah i
think like you can't they can't just
fall back and do the exact same thing
again no so there's one thing they could
do differently
is is what we're talking about exactly
like otherwise everything adds up to
like it's it has to add up to something
or else it's
what's the point right to make
however like a billion dollars
yeah i forgot about money and yeah i
mean i'm not again i'm just playing
devil's advocate i would love for them
to actually tell like a well-made story
but i think
battlefield 1 when they were showing
their trailer and everything and they're
like it's really going to be about the
the causes of the people that take place
in the war but it's not it was they made
you look heroic you're into this the
[ __ ] suit of armor coming across a
battlefield with a machine gun like
they're not
i mean again i'm just i'm just
i think it's my instinct to hear this pr
stuff and say okay well let's wait until
november and then i'll i doubt call of
duty's gonna do it but
it can still be fun i'm not saying it's
not going to be like i want to ask you
about multiplayer and loadouts which is
completely contrary to what we're
talking about now right right
i still i i have a hard time listening
to activision and sledgehammers saying
they're going to do that when
i i'm almost positive they won't oh yeah
i mean they can say that they want to do
that
what from what i saw there's potential
for them to do that is basically um what
my preview is about um but yeah if you
want to talk about multiplayer we know
very little yeah um to move on to less
uh to lighter stuff yeah what do you
know about multiplayer uh did they even
say anything at the event
barely i mean we we saw
the the teaser image like that two
second thing from the the live stream
was more than i saw at the event um
basically the one thing is they're the
big thing that stood out to me was
they're adding a new uh it's called war
mode and it's supposed to be like
narrative driven um axis versus allies
iconic world war ii battles so
it's uh i forget what the mode is called
in battlefield one operations yes yes
um and so it sounded sort of in that
vein um but i i don't know anything else
about it and the the other weird thing
was that they're uh doing something
called headquarters which is like a
social space that sounds like destiny's
tower
um or uh titanfall's titanfall 2's uh
their lobby system yeah
was it called it was a clan system well
forget what it's called i don't remember
but okay sorry go but this sounds more
like opposed to like an a menu this
sounds it's like an actual like walking
space it's that's what it sounds like
it's like an actual location so not a
multiplayer lobby but like a plate like
and it was like you get rewards and
recognition i'm like is that a cool
outfit like what what does that mean
that
sounds so dumb
like that time setting but it's like i'm
never going to get into a multiplayer
match just hang out hq i'm not [ __ ]
fighting i just want to hear a little
kid singing frozen songs
i'm like we're too setting like it's
just gonna be like
it's gonna be an aneurysm watching
yeah so
not sure what that means um again very
few details the other thing was like oh
there's divisions it sounds like classes
like oh it can be infantry division or
armored division um and then
of course take a shot every time they
say boots on the ground um that was the
other bullet point was boots on the
ground gameplay so obviously like that
means tdm and all that stuff most likely
i would
you would shock me if you were like oh
yeah they got rid of team deathmatch
yeah you're like yeah you're stupid so
um yeah yeah a whole lot to go off of
i do want to talk about the
co-op teaser that they they showed oh
[ __ ] yeah i didn't see any of that i
figured it was going to be something
zombies related but yeah they basically
show a nazi zombie
this would be the first time
sledgehammer would have done zombies
because last week no they did exo
zombies oh they did that x the dumb one
and yeah
no they've done advanced warfare yeah
but in terms of like
zombies like infinite warfare because
infinity ward for the first time did it
with infinite warfare right uh
zombies in spaceland was their first
zombies foray um and so this wouldn't be
sledgehammers first but it would be more
in line with uh treyarch zombies i get i
mean like that's the impression i got
from the one image they showed and the
fact that they were like ah it's about
the third reich doing stuff and i was
like all right that sounds like fine
stuff yeah it sounds like
me oh my god mike wanted to talk about
wolfenstein we just got triggered
segway on purpose no no sorry finish
your co-op
that's all because i'm so excited
because rob looks really mad
no i'm more mad he i'm not i never
i never said
you are being a glump right now i never
said
that new order was better than cafe
castle wolfenstein why are we talking
because it is the most it is the best
most recent world war ii game
even though it's alternate history i
didn't say it has to be
historical dang hey throw hands right
now say i don't like castle wolfenstein
it's like dude
the new order is one of the best
shooters in the last do i like poison
yeah
did you oh my god the band
[Music]
sorry co-op in
call of duty world war ii has you
excited because of the third reich doing
i wouldn't say i'm excited i'm just i
wanted to talk about it
i'm i'm they didn't say anything at the
event so that was like a surprise to me
during this live stream um yeah so they
showed one picture of a zombie looking
dude and they're like this is co-op and
uh i i mean that's to be expected but
i'm interested i should say to see what
they do with it i'd be interested to see
like how much money they make off like
zombies dlc because maybe they're just
making so much off that they're like all
three studios have to do zombies now
it's their remember community man there
is a stronghold
i love zombies too it's gained so much
momentum that yeah i wonder if they like
cannot now
i'm sorry they have to do with zombies
every time we were talking about modern
warfare 2's uh spec ops co-op stuff i
really like that
i was hoping for yeah or and to have it
more of a narrative or just like you
know one-off missions like stealth like
there are some good ones in those spec
ops like as far as teamwork goes right
buddy i mean who it could be like that
we don't know anything about how it'll
actually play out they just showed we
have the story on the site now i think
um they just showed an image of
a zombified
great dude um so who knows if it's going
to be like they said it was going to be
a
new story so it could be more
story-driven i don't know okay we don't
know a whole lot about those two things
we know the most about single player so
nazi zombies are returning no
they're already here right now
like here in the middle of the warfare
yeah yeah that'd be a sick way to end
this nice don't know
yes november third uh call of duty world
war ii i'm sure we'll know more in the
coming months especially with e3 on the
horizon i don't know if they're doing a
call of duty xp event again down in l.a
um oh yeah i've i keep forgetting we
were both there because yeah yeah um i
didn't really enjoy that
yeah no um sorry activision i know it's
yeah uh no but the oh i guess i should
mention that the uh multiplayer will be
playable on the show floor at e3 oh cool
so
that might mean there's no call of duty
xp because uh e3 is open to the public
this year so that's sort of the
opportunity for them to show that off to
fans
um
so yeah i mean we'll learn more about
multiplayer and presumably co-op around
e3
cool uh sweet so november 3rd will be
call of duty world war ii uh on ps4 xbox
one pc as usual from sledgehammer it's
their turn with the call of duty
franchise for the year before it goes
back to treyarch next year if they keep
that trend going which i'm sure they
will because i'm sure this game will
make a lot of money we'll see how it
goes i'm excited to see more about
multiplayer the trailer i think i'm a
little lukewarm on i think i got too
many battlefield one save and private
ryan
uh banner brothers vibes i wanted to
show that shot it was a very yeah yeah
it was a very very or like dunkirk even
now you know the stupas the propellers
and stuff that's cool
i'm looking forward to seeing more from
it but uh let us know what you think let
us know whether your plan if this is
going to pull you back to the call of
duty franchise if you've been away for
it for a while from it for a while let
us know what you think and uh if you're
in the chat here while we wrap up let us
know what you think leave your thoughts
in the comments below if you're watching
this on youtube or gamespot after the
fact
we'll wait well that's a show
um hey guys after you're reviewing
siberia three i am i need to wrap that
up because peter's gonna get mad at me
yeah
don't get mad at me yeah he's not this
is the first time he hasn't been on the
show in a while i forgot to mention that
he is uh meeting with some people here
in the office so he couldn't make it ooh
callie what are you up to this week
uh yeah call of duty stuff um luckily i
got a bunch of stuff published today so
i think i'm okay
uh i'm reviewing a game and
yeah i don't think i can say what the
game is gotcha
rob what about you you're just gonna be
playing titanfall
new update
um i don't know i'm gonna be hanging out
you know chatting with everyone what
character is this
what is he doing all right
uh yeah so like we said earlier 2pm
pacific friday mario kart tournament um
they still have not figured out what
prize to give me when i win yet but
i forgot what i'm doing is training to
beat mike that's what i'm saying oh
thanks so much for coming we'll see you
friday hopefully uh in the meantime stay
tuned to gamespot for more call of duty
news as it comes out in the coming weeks
and uh with more stuff surfacing before
e3 comes out we'll have a lot of news
coming out from gamespot uh plenty of
reviews dawn of war dragon quest heroes
two what remains of finch outlast two
holy [ __ ] there's a lot of games out
right now uh looking forward to pray
we'll have a stream next week we can get
more to that next week but until then
have a good week
[Music]
okay